así que está muy buenos días es el
centro nacional de huracanes están muy
pendientes de la trayectoria de esta
tormenta tropical en la obra que avanza
poco a poco por el atlántico ya ha
pasado por puerto rico también por cuba
donde ha dejado fuertes lluvias e
inundaciones y ahora se dirige por el
golfo de méjico a algún punto de
luisiana texas donde los meteorólogos
han avisado que podría llegar con
vientos de más de 170 kilómetros por
hora y convertido en huracanes de
categoría dos en florida florida el
estado de florida se salva aunque en el
sur en los cayos se ha decretado el
estado de emergencia porque también se
podrían registrar fuertes inundaciones
pero también tenemos que estar muy
pendientes de la tormenta tropical al
marco que ya avanza poco a poco por el
golfo de méxico con vientos de 96
kilómetros por hora ya ha degradado a
tormenta tropical aunque se había
convertido en huracán pero los expertos
del centro nacional de huracanes avisan
que se podría crear un fenómeno sin
precedentes y es que por primera vez en
la historia se podrían encontrar dos
ciclones de estas categorías
el golfo de mexico anthony muchísimas
gracias por este reporte estaremos bien
atento a lo que suceda en eeuu con la
tormenta del aura